chris flexon who is a native californian
he was originally drafted by the vets
out of high school last year he pitched
in korea well and then that's where he
came back to the states he was over in
the kbo the 412 era at home he's 216.
he's the next offer on the way swinging
the ground ball right past the pitcher
back into the ball behind the back jp
crawford fires across the first and it's
in time to rob charlie blackman what a
play by the gold glover jp crawford and
that will retire the side he was on the
other side of second kyle freeland the
starter for the rockies tonight 28 years
of age left-hander oh and two with a 9.5
a dra in five starts a 2-2 to crawford
swing in a miss
on an off-speed pitch for strike three
and the mariners have one out here in
the bottom of the first no score in the
ball game
and a swing and a miss on a hard slider
and hanukkah goes down on strikes back
to back punch outs to begin the evening
pitch
he drives it to the right field blackman
going back at the track makes the catch
for the out that came close we go to the
top half of the second mariners of the
rockies no score story outstanding
player but right now batting 259 he has
six home runs 29 runs banded in he's
going to be a free agent at the end of
the year here's the one-two pitch swing
and a miss for strike three got him with
a fastball
chris flexon with strikeout number one
he gets trevor story leading off the top
of the second the set by flexon and the
right-handers 1-2 on the way to hampson
swing adamus for strike three got him on
a fastball
so a couple of strikeouts for flexon
here in the top of the second that's it
for the rockies we go to the bottom of
any number two gorgeous night here in
seattle for the opening game of the
series day off yesterday here's the
wind-up and the 1-1 pitch swung on fly
ball right center field falling fast
dawes on the run dives and he can't
continue the ball gets behind him bauer
is heading for second up of the ball is
blackman now the long throw to third
will keep bowers to a one-out double
a ten game hitting streak adding on to a
career best run a couple of looks back
to the runner and the pitch to murphy
swing and a miss
there's another
hard slider
slash cutter strikeout number three
3-1 pitch is popped up
shallow left field
tapia wants it and stayed with it to
make the catch freeland is in his third
start your t-mobile park a 1-0 record
one-two pitch swing and a miss
got him down and in for another
strikeout number four for kyle freeland
freeland as he gets set to go back to
work kicks and fires swung on and a
sharp grounder to crone who gobbles it
up at first takes a step and touches
first base and it's a one two three
inning for kyle freeland three complete
in seattle
a low strikeout rate guy daza doesn't
walk much but doesn't strike out a whole
lot until right now as he chases after
an elevated 95 mile an hour heater
two-two to story swing and a miss for
strike three got him that is strike on
number four for chris flexon and another
one two three any
two-two pitch breaking ball bounced to
the left side fuentes gives ground
gloves quick throw and krone able to
keep that right foot on the bag for the
out good play on both ends fuentes and
crone one man down freeland looking in
and the pitch to france swung on and hit
in the air center field dazza moving
back still shy of the track he'll make
the catch and freeland shuts the door in
the fourth one out for brendan rodgers
and brendan smokes it to the left side
and there's the rocky's first hit of the
night
here we go again another one-two pitch
and a swing and a miss for strike three
and flexon wins the battle
he strikes out joshua fuentes for
strikeout number five
one out two on first time the mariners
have had two men on base tonight here is
dylan moore trying to cash in
it's in left field for a basement here
comes murphy he is being held at third
as tapia got to it quickly wise moved by
maniac to the mariners have him loaded
they stack three straight singles the
mariners have the bases loaded with one
out we'll try again with a one-two pitch
swag and a miss he got him went upstairs
with a hard slider and long is strikeout
victim number five and out number two
the runners take off three two pitch
swung on ground ball left side rogers
the backhand the long throw to first
head first slide crawford safe at first
one run scores now they have a throw to
second base and dylan moore is out
trying to get back to second meriters
get a run and they get the lead but the
inning is over chris flexing throwing a
beauty a one-hit shutout he struck out
five walk two swinging on a miss pulled
a chain on him right there nice change
up at 83 miles an hour to six strikeouts
[Applause]
chopping to crawford
he's got it on to first base plenty of
time inning over that'll do it for the
rockies in the sixth
0-2 again breaking ball strike three
called
dandy hook there by kyle freeland
kyle gets strikeout number six another
row two to france and got him to chase a
breaking ball in the dirt swag and a
miss strikeout number seven for kyle
freeland chris flexing throwing a beauty
two hit shutouts struck out six walk two
here's cj cronin swings and drives it to
right field moving back haniger and that
is over and out of here
cj crone goes the other way and he gets
the home run and the rockies have tied
the game at one
and this ball's well hit the center
field this ball's got some carry and
this ball is going to short hop the wall
and rogers ain't stopping at second he's
on his way to third
it's a triple for brendan rodgers the
rockies
have the go-ahead run 90 feet from home
with two outs in the seventh now flexson
will exit to a
ruckus round of applause as he pitches
into the seventh and is done with two
outs kicks and deals swung on and hit
right to bowers at first base he'll take
it himself
wins the race to the bag and that'll do
it a run on two heads no errors in a man
left here's shed long he won the game on
sunday with a grand slam in the 10th
wrench and the 1-1 pitch swinging a fly
ball in the center feeling deep gaza
going back going back looking up goodbye
baseball shed long junior has just
belted the 7 000 home run in the history
of the seattle mariners holy smokes and
it breaks the 1-1 tie
greatman 1-0 with a 1.31 era his 19th
appearance of the year coming up right
here five saves
and the right-handers one-two pitch
swinging a ground fall out to moore at
second he's got it the throw to first
and the ball game is over the mariners
won it two to one they've won five in a
row